and here's the thing is that do people
are people not allotted
uh mistakes you know what i mean
sometimes you need to make that mistake
in order for you to reflect on it and
get better from it
you know sometimes yeah you might say
something that's misguided or ignorant
and then somebody calls you out on it
and you know
the hope from there is that you're able
to reflect on it like
be able to be honest with yourself not
get so defensive not put your shields up
be like
okay maybe there's a possibility here
that i [ __ ] up maybe
i gotta look into what it is that i'm
thinking and what it is that i said
or what it is that i did even um and see
reevaluate this
and then learn from it but then if
you're talking about oh because this
person [ __ ] up you automatic we should
cancel this person
then you're essentially saying people
aren't allowed to make mistakes
sometimes people do
stupid things and especially when it's
in the past
right and then you haven't seen these
type of behaviors reflected in who they
are now yeah
then i honestly what's the whole point
of digging something up that happened 10
years ago that isn't a reflection
of the person that you see before you
yeah the content that they create right
so i'll give a great example so
i have a couple friends of mine um they
did this video
um they basically played this game
and it's it's terrible not even in
hindsight what they did it was pretty
bad right
and so they were drawing this
uh it was this this is what the game is
let me just preface that
so the game was you have a hat and
inside this hat are a bunch of people
that is it is impossible to make fun of
right
that is the whole stick of the game okay
and so they had a lot of people and they
had like jesus whatever the dalai lama
whoever you could
name it one of the names that was in
that hat was uh trayvon martin
okay uh it got drawn and the person who
made that joke yeah
wasn't my friends it was the other this
was shane dawson he's under a fire for a
lot of things we'll talk about that
another time
and he made a joke about trayvon martin
the kid who was murdered
and he said um uh maybe you wouldn't
have gotten murdered if you had a job
and it's like what the [ __ ] you know
like what the [ __ ] were you thinking
right but they got burned because they
they kind of they laughed at the joke it
doesn't help
that they're white yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying
and so they put out a public apology
video and you guys know who they are
they're stephen nicki so steve and nicky
put out a public apology video
the first one that they did wasn't that
great um i don't think they awarded it
very well i think they got scared
and so they wanted to put out a quick
apology video but they did a second one
which was a lot better and they
apologized for it yeah they apologize
what
what how it hurt the community
specifically in these times right now
and a lot of people are asking me it's
like well you're doing these why don't
you roast them
i was like because they apologized yeah
they were quick about it right they
apologized they made these videos
and because they are my personal friends
do they get preferential treatment of
course they [ __ ] do we have a
personal [ __ ] relationship yeah
if before i even got to contact them
they already apologized yeah
exactly so what do i need to do call
them up and be like hey
you should apologize yeah they already
did yeah so they
they knew that they [ __ ] up yeah they
knew that it happened in the past and
they
and they already put that video down
prior before
um before the whole blm movement
happened they didn't take it down
because of blm they took it down
years ago because they looked back on it
they thought it was [ __ ] up yeah
but um there was a kid named jay versace
who i do follow this kid's [ __ ] funny
he put their stuff out and he put them
on blast and so
um they took that small clip and i think
like the original apology it was done
kind of too suddenly yeah so it kind of
came off as if they were
trying to make excuses for their
behavior but it really wasn't the case
and when they came out with the second
apology which is how they really felt
and they better awarded it it showed
change
right and i i know them personally they
don't have like a
hateful racist bone in their [ __ ]
body yeah and because i have that
personal relationship and i haven't seen
that from them
in the three four years that i've known
i can i can vouch for them and say that
yeah they still have to apologize which
they already did so what's the whole
point of me
taking the clip of the video and doing
an angry rant about them when
i can just talk to them yeah and that's
the biggest fundamental difference
though is that
you know some of these people that
you've roasted they get defensive and
actually double down sometimes yes they
do on what they said they're not taking
a moment to reflect and being like oh
[ __ ]
maybe i did something wrong or said
something wrong here maybe i should you
know
uh reevaluate and apologize i mean some
of these people are not doing that so
when you've taken the moment to reflect
on what it is that you did
and you know everybody processes it
differently you could you could learn
about it
uh same day or you might need to take a
week or two weeks or whatever right
whatever the case is once you come to
the conclusion i [ __ ] up here
and since i did that publicly i need to
offer up an apology publicly as well
um then yeah what is there to roast
about that and yeah
they already apologize yeah and look i
could see the argument of oh you know
but they only did it because they got
attacked
again there are plenty of other people
who are getting attacked who will not
offer you an apology who will double
down on what they're saying get
defensive about what they're saying and
stick to their guns
you know yeah and i've like i said i
know them i've had personal
conversations with them
and their situation too are
i mean nikki she's like part filipino
and whatever right that girl is white as
[ __ ]
she's as white as it [ __ ] gets you
know and
you know the girl grew up uh around a
majority of [ __ ] white people
and you know steve is as wide as it gets
it doesn't help steve's case that he
looks like a kkk member too
i'm [ __ ] with you i love you but you
know
he looks like prototypically he could be
a racist if you take a look at them
but in their case i know them so yeah
they do get a pass because i could just
talk to them personally i don't have to
do a rant video i
know them yeah i can call them up and be
like bro what the [ __ ] were you thinking
yeah
but then when i saw the video it was
from years ago and i know that they
already took that video down prior
before because they knew how dumb it was
yeah
they already learned from this i haven't
seen the reflection in that so these
people have grown from the situation
so what's the whole point of beating
somebody down
um and trying to correct the behavior
they've already corrected themselves
and and look that's that's what i'm
saying is like people
are one super hyper sensitive
um and two is they won't do their due
diligence as well because sometimes
it's like they'll you know some type
some something's going on an event or
whatever
and um you know i'll look at twitter as
one of the outlets for like
real-time news updates and then i'll see
certain things like maybe supplemental
evidence coming
out of a certain incident right of yeah
there's a behavior of this pattern
whatever
but sometimes that's just straight up
[ __ ] it's just straight up made up
you know and people start thinking oh
yeah that's
valid evidence because somebody tweeted
it and posted it out yeah you know
it's like no you got to do your due
diligence too do they have a history of
this behavior
you know or or is this more like a
momentary lapse in judgment
is there is there is just a [ __ ] up
right and can they come back from this
yeah it's because a lot of some of y'all
[ __ ] act like you're perfect
if i look the only difference between
you and some of these other people and i
guarantee you've probably done way more
[ __ ] up things than these people have
and haven't learned from that is that
they're in the public eye the public
figures for sure
you're no [ __ ] different and some of
you are 10 times [ __ ] worse like
there was a
i'll give the greatest example remember
that one girl who wore that chinese
dress
for her prom and the people were
flipping out about it saying it was
cultural appropriation
that this chinese dress isn't your
[ __ ] costume or whatever
yeah but this dude but this asian that
attacked her people found his tweets and
he was dropping the n bomb with a hard r
like [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you think you
are you're talking about cultural
appropriation and being racist
you're 10 times worse she just wore a
dress and she
looked good and the funny thing was in
that situation people in china were like
what's the problem she looked good
like she looks so good
yeah but this guy wanted to make a big
deal about it because for some reason it
bothered him
when he's the wrong he's the one going
around saying racial obscenities about
another culture and another race so
how are you any different so it makes me
wonder about people who are pointing
these fingers so [ __ ] hard
like what's what are the closets that
you're hiding yeah or the skeletons in
your closet that you're hiding yeah i
mean the thing is is that
sometimes uh well that's